are your walls doing enough for you are
they smart enough do they spend way too
much time holding up the ceiling and
dividing your home into rooms shouldn't
they also be listening to you and
anticipating your every need
researchers have now found a way to make
the most responsive walls yet imagine
for example as you sit down on the sofa
the tv turns on lights dim when you
start watching something on your laptop
or Alexa lets you know that your kids
have turned on a portable videogame
system somewhere in the house this isn't
very difficult to do the first step is
converting a wall into a giant antenna
in this study researchers used tape to
make a grid on the wall then covered it
over with water-based paint containing
nickel they remove the tape which left
behind a pattern of metallic diamonds to
act as electrodes then they connected
two electrodes to a computer and painted
the wall with standard latex paint
hiding any signs of its new capabilities
now the wall can watch your every move
touching or moving an arm or limb close
to the wall changes the walls
electrostatic fields just as a finger
touching an iPad does it can tell if
you're exercising or heading for the
kitchen and if connected to your house
computer may one day turn on energizing
music or flip the kitchen lights on the
newly alert wall can even sense what you
are interacting with in the room lamps
laptops TVs and other electronic devices
all generate distinctive electromagnetic
fields eventually such walls which the
team created for $20 per square meter in
this study could feed this information
to electronic personal assistants or
your phone when you're not home
hopefully not the government
[Music]
[Music]